Say you're given this pipeline. You're told that the fragment shader is turning
out to be a huge bottleneck in this extremely primitive GPU design made by Acme
GPU's and Bubblegum, Incorporated. Their GPU has a single vertex shader and a
single fragment shader processor. This is pretty pitiful and, in fact, is what
differentiates different GPU's in the same class. Some will be more powerful
simply because they have more shaders on the chip. Modern GPU's process
hundreds, if not thousands, of vertices and pixels simultaneously with these
cores, which is why they are called massively parallel. Acme knows that they'll
need to add more cores to be competitive, so they're making a much larger chip.
They know that it'll be able to have a few hundred separate vertex shaders and
separate fragment shaders, plus room for other features. You've been hired to
design their next chip, which will have many more transistors available. Your
team brainstorms a few architectural ideas and you're asked to evaluate these.
Your task is to decide what's worth considering. Reverse the order performing
the fragment shader before the vertex shader, test the z-depth before running
the fragment shader and abort if test fails, rework the shader cores so they
can be used as vertex shaders or fragment shaders, and the last idea is divide
each triangle into four smaller triangles and render these. Personally, I think
half of these ideas are worth exploring further.